What in the world are you doing?
>> Oh I, I'm just pretending I'm inside a cell, and I just transcribed a gene,
and so I've got the RNA and now I'm cutting and pasting all the exons together.
>> But how do you know where to cut?
>> Oh, well that's easy. Because the exons and
introns are colored here, the exons are in purple.
And the entrons are in orange and I am
essentially taking and cutting out the entrons and keeping
the xons.
>> So we keep the xons, but we get rid of the entrons?
>> Exactly and what sounds a kind of intuitive, but we keep
the xons and we cut out the entrons. So that's why the mRNA's
shorter than the gene, because we're actually getting rid of some of
the gene sequence. Except for the ones that only have one exon, right?
>> That's exactly right. Now, most genes have more than one exon. There are
a few that have only one. But those genes that have more than one exon
have to cut out all those introns,
in a process called splicing. That's what splicing
is, we cut out, splice out, the introns, and we splice together All the exons.
>> Can we infer anything about the number of
introns and exons based on the length of the mRNA?
>> So I want you to tell me, here 2 mRNA's made from their
respective genes. Here is the DNA gene and the mRNA copy that resulted. Another
DNA gene and its mRNA copy that resulted. After
transcription. I want you to tell me for both examples,
how many axons do you think are in each
gene? So here are the genes, on the left and
right, and beneath them are MRNA copies. And just
to be clear, on the left, the MRNA copy is
the exact length as the DNA gene. And over
here on the right, the mRNA copy is shorter than
the DNA gene, so using the options below for each scenario, I want
you to pick the best answer for the question, how many exons do you
think are in each gene? This is a tough one, so think about
it first, and try again if you don't get it the first go around.